hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to do maternal there's
some dudes in need of being purged right
here wouldn't you know it it's awful
funny oh hey did I get it well I bet I
got it no I didn't get it oh I got it on
my way to being sticky bomb master but
I'm not there yet
get out of my way I need to get this guy
yeah choo whoa what missed you there we
go
ah that sucks for you whoa hello where
did you come from
wow I see you sneaky beaky I'm out of
ammo yep got you with a grenade launcher
alright you you you you forget whoa nope
you go down fall down fall down there we
go all right Mike
who else wants to tangu no one I had all
this room to play with I didn't even
move around not that I needed to I was
doing fine by myself Ice Arena though
that they made here all right big beefy
guns look like they need to be big be
fully fired now how do I get over there
hmm
am i stupid ah
ah come on it looks like oh portal we're
playing portal now well oh shoot
okay we played portal easy enough for me
man this UAC if they hadn't been so evil
maybe they could have done some good
you'd think that Samuel Hadden being the
head of the UAC would have noticed that
his entire organization was being
crafted from within but apparently not
oh well too bad for him he's only a
robot it's not like he's human or
anything oh yes oh I thought it was just
gonna be a button whoa you mean I don't
actually get to shoot it I just get to
watch it be shot but that's not the same
but that's not the same guys guys
developers you not only didn't let me
act like I was shooting it from the
perspective but you didn't let me press
the button let me shoot a big gun you
want a wasted opportunity I know it's
just a shoot a tentacle but let me do
that and why cut away to a third-person
perspective when I would have seen it
with my own eyes right then and there
it's the first time I have a legitimate
complaint in this game that probably
will have more but come on now what's
wrong with you I guess I'll leave then
oh well just gonna be sad for a bit that
I didn't get to do that now maybe you
guys should focus on what's important
like being dead there you go
sorry about them
now you're all dead hello I see you join
you [ __ ] turned around man sorry bub
very unfortunate for you something tells
me that they don't mind tainted ground
considering their ground is primarily
made of taints elevator I can't move why
am i stuck in the elevator why are they
freezing me in place on some things that
doesn't make sense like an elevator why
would oh really that's how it's gonna be
huh
hey oh that was not I thought I had the
super shotgun apparently I did not all
right hello the return of dr. Samuel
Aidan okay this should be interesting
the destruction of the argent well
spring on Mars meant chaos for planet
Earth following the loss of
communication between Earth and Mars
based facilities the collapse of the
arts independent energy grid consume the
planet in crisis it was during this time
that UAC director Samuel Hayden suddenly
resurfaced on earth before the a in
Council wielding that which might offer
salvation to mankind the crucible after
recounting the events that had
transpired on the Red Planet Hayden
agreed to cooperate with the a.n
providing access to various UAC
facilities on earth and by extension the
full range of technologies and its
disposal paramount among these was the
crucible the last remaining source of
origin energy in existence well I mean
there seems to be a lot floating around
in demon form right now why don't you
just pluck that out of this guy seems
that depending on making your entire
energy system dependent on one source of
energy may not have been the wisest of
decisions maybe doom boy here was right
maybe you should have been wise to his
ways
now how about you stop in your tracks
there buddy boom boom be really not that
you're so so strong from the front um I
shouldn't have wasted that question I
knew it you trick me let's get down to
business
come on there it is
there it is boom pieces go everywhere
pieces go come on ma
what is this Oh what did I get
oh wait I should be using this by far I
should ha ha ha ha ha ha Oh overheated
that's that thing hasn't overheating I
didn't know that that's what that was
oh I don't have unlimited anymore
get out of my way these [ __ ] get out
of my way
No what the hell just happened
whoop it stopped me in my tracks boum
boum boum
sorry about you you lost your ear head
privileges nice whoa oh yeah but you
need a blood punch don't you
[Music]
well you're already dead never mind
blood punch over anyone else that all
where he was he just providing a hole in
the ground for me to go and do seems
like that was the case but there is also
a goodie over here hello alright how
many more of these do I possibly need
yeah good enough equipment I mean that
could be good for me to get more flame
belch stuff which is always good I
suppose now the question is where is
Sammy boy where is the Sam ster said
he's just a husk of his former self so
where is he
hi
oh really gonna shove me into that are
you oh god oh god how many of y'all got
I'm stuck I'm stuck no not today
boom okay we're fine II there's a bit of
a challenge when I'm not able to move at
all
I get it I get what you're going for oh
no here we go Oh No
listen you big boys you need to tone it
down
bonk big big boy is a big big dead how
do I get up out of here can I climb on
this thing this sure does seem like
something that like Mario Super Mario
World style would be able to climb upon
but apparently I cannot I don't think
this is doing anything but it feels good
because otherwise I got nothing to live
for
boom oh thanks thanks thank you
perfect exactly what I was hoping for
excellent love it
go incus now nothing else there all
right moving on
hi buds
thank you they died so quick I can't
even glory kill them for your need your
poor knee die bud
alright let's do this Sammy Sam sir why
do they lock me off in the elevator uh
huh at least like some freedom please
yes yes
nice feeling it feeling good okay so
there's a lock door back there down on
up since you're how to open it maybe
through here
hello could that do what I think it
might have done
yes it did hi well this looks fun what's
here the return of dr. Samuel Hayden
well this looks that looks like some
kind of religious iconography there
methinks this Samuel Hayden might have
some kind of an ego about him all right
whatever believing it possible to solve
the energy crisis which now devastated
the planet dr. Hayden saw to invent a
method of argent synthesis a synthetic
replication of that could recreate the
high yield capability of origin energy
with the destruction of the Arts and
energy across the solar system all that
remain of origin existed now within the
crucible the fabled hell artifact which
dr. Hayden had acquired on Mars knowing
full well the crucibles hidden powered
Samuel devised a method to utilize the
artifact it's an argent conductor a
process that would in time produce the
miracle of synthetic man-made arch and
energy restoring the production of
argent energy to earth Hayden became a
mythical figure among Earth's survivors
in no small part due to his abnormal
physical condition having returned to
earth when most saw a means to escape
bringing with him the crucible that
would grant the people a second chance
at survival for the common person he had
become the stuff of legends seems
awfully convenient and I still don't
trust him very much
seems like he's up to no good hmm pick
up 20 extra lives total and a single
saves lon
well is that all it takes god I really
got to use my big blaster some more
which I'm going to now but I've still
got to use it more quad machine love it
all right what do we got
Wow sorry but you get blasted oh oh oh
oh oh you're gonna take too long
never mind too quick
do not shoot uh looks like someone shot
I don't know what that's from is this a
reference to something this is the first
time I've seen graffiti on here hmm
maybe maybe like something from Dhoom 3
or dead space or something like that or
maybe it's not a reference to anything
at all maybe it's just something to
someone wrote either way time to go hmm
let me guess another elevator I'm gonna
be locked in and a gun I'm not gonna be
able to fire it sure would have been fun
to be able to fire it sure would have
been great what was that down there what
did I see okay seem to be bypassing a
lot of the levels that I would like to
go to all right
sure let's not fire this
locked sure looks locked
override successful okay thanks
now is super satisfied I like how that
helicopters blades turned into limp
dicks every time a helicopter crashes it
just becomes limp dick no sustainability
in the structural integrity of those
they just follow the pieces yep
just like that all right I'm down and
also I'm locked in place here I can't
move
why can't I move I don't know I don't
know whoever designed these turrets
wasn't thinking about the players game
experience they do do doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo
oh never mind who's a shrine to my
greatness thank you thank you very much
really appreciate that that's very nice
of you oh all right never mind
hello really really
thank you thank you
thank you
anyone else all right cool I'm not
locked in there with you oh you're a big
you're a big boy let me uh never mind
he's gone hey anything in here I can
press No all right
carrying on my way then that looks fun
point
[Applause]
lover
man
how many of these do you take
Oh y'all done oh dude guys I'm at full
health I'm waiting for more that's all
you're gonna give me just those dudes
really you're not gonna oh there we go
that's what I'm talking about oh sorry
your guns they go a couple and you go
kaboom afterwards oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah whoo yo yo yo
oh this guy's real good about getting me
on those those seem way too accurate for
their own good did you just make me
waste my blood punch overkill for you
sir
point is that all more more please sir
may I have some more oh hi I was open
for more enemies but I guess it's coin
oh there's a secret up there there's a
log I feel like this is a good
opportunity was actually doom if my
family tree deviated a little bit a
little bit more than it did or take a
different path my last name would
literally be doomed spell do om take
that for what you will it's literally
meaningless but I'm taking some pride in
that my great-grandmother's name was
commonly known as mamma doom and her
meatloaf recipe is great I still cook it
to this day very very good meatloaf hey
I'm here again did they really call them
the mortally tuned
pop we actually like the the the sniper
a little better but I am out of I am out
of a lot of goodies can i hey thank you
thank you
hey thanks for that sweet good timing my
friend good hey you ain't come over here
oh there is that a quad damage I see yes
please okay wait what what mmm that was
not supposed to go that way
yes thank you why do they call it
onslaught pretty sure it's just quad
damage hello is anybody here have I
gotten like all the secrets I've been
doing damn good on finding these things
damn good let me tell you okay tell me
more about how great I am our salvation
Thank You strength so do they fall in
numbers the priests command the armies
to the north and south but he controls
the fight oh yeah that I have faith the
Slayer is the spear that stabs at the
heart of our attackers and those that
would seek to harm us should feel warned
dominant life-form in this universe and
it carries a steel barreled sword of
vengeance destroy the Slayers time is
now okay getting a little cringy now you
know it's starting to become too
reverent you know the praise is nice
don't get me wrong
love the praise praise is great praise
real cool but uh yeah he's starting to
become like a super fan and it's getting
a little much you know I just think
maybe you should tone it down a little
bit you know tone it down just for your
own good for both of our goods for
everyone's goods
just tone it down okay cool we good cool
thanks if you're still alive if you get
super clingy I'm gonna have to peace out
you know how it is life it's about the
road it can't can't can't be hanging
about too long am I not going in oh I
gotta push the button I actually get to
push a button this time
laboratory facility yes well that
doesn't sound good
oh hi my god hi thanks my big meaty
claws cool uh I'll be I'll be going he
hoped sorry
and I dr. Hayden are you up here
emergency protocols have been activated
please exit the facility now hi
well well well we uh we don't know how
to access his main cortex it's all alien
we couldn't figure it out we have to
prepare from here careful yeah let me
show you how careful is well he's a
robot I think he'll be fine
laboratory oh hi hey baby
are you doing look I have beaten you
before I took the hard road to get to
BCU and I have been waiting for this
moment no no no no no no no no no no no
oh yeah no I don't think so
uh-huh all right cool yeah no III know
all about this dude now dude I am so
about destroying this dude in a million
ways
no thank you hi I don't need any of that
can you woo why is he so close get back
get back get back get back he's he
really wants to be all up on me come huh
come on what are you doing
hi what are you doing are you doing miss
bear now you got to kiss me come on
shotgun ease shotgun you think you you
think you can toe-to-toe with me the
answer is that maybe you know what do I
get what do I get what do I got
woo everybody hey baby
we got we got what you got what you got
huh what you got what are you what are
you oh [ __ ] missed ya Eve's alright
we're doing this
oh yeah we're doing this baby we're
doing this honk I didn't even get to
savor it it was too fast didn't get to
savor it Oh didn't even get to taste it
you know I'm taking that one off you
know I don't even want to do glory kills
faster I'll just do them farther away
because I don't need them faster to be
perfectly honest give me back home baby
mmm oh it feels good Wow Oh ch a legit I
never do the challenges cuz they never
read what they are overload a shield to
kill six demons I wasn't paying
attention there weren't that many yeah
it's fine I got all the goodies and
that's what really matters at the end of
the day mmm-hmm that feels nice I
whatever I don't care about the rewards
when he's experienced I'm getting the
experience in my skills right in my
fingers that's where the experience that
really counts goes everyone knows this
I'm I'm pretty good at that Sam wake up
Sam architecture is similar to a zone
finally I sand the car the only
functional Slipgate to set my crime is
in the core of Mars in the lost city of
the death I have marked its location for
you but getting there will take time
there is no easy way to access the are
you telling me I'm pretty sure I can man
dude I am pretty sure I can my boy
my man look I'm about to shoot this
that's what I'm about to do so I hope
you're ready for that what is that right
there
what do we have here is this what some
might call a secret there's something
down there
there's something right down there no no
no there's something down there there's
something down there it's right there
which way would you like me to go for it
is there a way to get down there for me
yes there is okay so I gotta go here to
get that I don't need this outfit I
don't but I spy a secret I want to get a
piece of that wasting to Sentinel
batters do this I wish I could pull them
out I can't I just reuse them
keep this door open forever yep
that's nice a classic thanks for the
lighting my bros my dudes and then down
here hi how you doing earth okay found
that okay time to put another key in the
slot hey baby don't worry I'm coming for
you I'll see you in a bit I will see you
baby I was used to baby baby on Maker I
will be there for you very soon who's
talking about me and has retrieved his
remains we do not know why unnamed
sources inside the organization claim
the dr. Hayden anticipated the Slayers
arrival we can only hope that this is
true and that the resistance can
continue well you'd be right about that
that is absolutely 100% true I me and
Sammy boy we go way way back we go way
back actually let me use some of my
points here going okay suit ah ba ba ba
Oh - refilled on glucose that's actually
gonna be useful for Cacodemons that
makes sense then whatever this is
sure whatever who cares all right let's
do this
with the help of Samuel Hayden the final
help priest has been located on Sentinel
Prime a city from your past the only
known path to this now Kirsten places
through the dimensional gateway hidden
in the core of Mars where in the lost
city of head Beth resides the journey
there will take you time you can't
afford to waste a dilemma which calls
for a more direct approach I remember
the BFG 10,000 wasn't that from the
first game I remember firing something
gigantically huge I do remember that
very specifically that was death
this this seems very wait this
this
this is familiar where was this did I
play this thanks buddy
hey y'all stay classy now I distinctly
remember this was this like an early
access thing hi
mind if I take this Thanks thanks buddy
yeah wait I remember doing this why do I
remember doing this shoot a hole in Mars
oh yes I love it
the power source of the BFG uh-huh why
you're gonna say why
hi bye bye guys can you point me in the
direction that I need to go I can't seem
to find it I'm a little lost bow hi bye
bye bye
hmm don't seem to be anybody here that
can help me find my way hello
I know you've got to stay alive a little
longer than that
hello thank you can you point me in the
direction of the BFG no thank you
all right cool priests thanks for
nothing I guess I think I remember this
being like some kind of early access
thing but I can't remember cuz I know
that I physically have fired the BFG hey
how you doing can I get some pchew oh I
wanna kill her I wanna kill them want to
kill them they're all dead
do I need another room how many rooms do
I need two more what's the point what is
even the point only people that are
scrubs need to actually slow down time
all right
oh my god
through the pipes is it now huh blood
Bunch baby blood punch did I get with
the employed punched
there you go buddy eat your medicine
[Music]
sure is firing a lot
nice um secret secrets doesn't seem to
be many secrets I think this is just
trying to get me to move quickly through
this area and get done although there's
something up there I saw secret hi bud
hey bud hey listen
am just dead hi listen can you
oh whoops meant to hit you with that
thank you dooba
damnit sure I'll take it
out what hit me and wha-ho where'd you
come from buddy
listen pal pal pal
well I'm stuck what am I stuck on Wow
why my son nope nope yeah I'm so slow
I'm so slow
give me something to shoot you are
coming with now garbage
what
done who knows I was trying to get down
uh-huh
what about it and these are a lot of
many BFG guns going off what are they
shooting at exactly because I don't
exactly see anything coming in what are
you shooting at what the hell is it
shooting at is there supposed to be like
an invasion ship in the sky or something
why are they just arbitrarily shooting
from the space is that accurate to what
the Sun would be at this distance what
are you shooting at what is what are you
shooting at okay there's a sentinel
battery somewhere over here where would
you be
aha ah ah I see okay maybe oh that's not
it oh come on that's so it you know it's
it you know that was it you know it
knows it knows that was it don't make me
feel silly okay
am I supposed to go down the maintenance
sense because that's what's oh my god it
is oh come on I thought he was gonna be
hidden not in plain sight uh it was
hidden in plain sight
hidden in
all right okay anyway BFG core sure oh
yeah this seems like the kind of thing
that I should just start punching at
random
Oh energy fuse gone all the control
systems for this destroyed weapon
destabilized never gonna be the same
again
[Music]
by
so now that I got the map there's
something up here something tells me
that this was like designed to be one of
the earliest levels and it was only
after the fact that they put it at this
point in the game because it feels like
something that's kind of an introductory
experience almost you know but it was
amped up in post to be a bit tougher cuz
I remember this being like an early
thing I bet you I bet in the original
design you did not get the floating base
that you have until later in the game
that was probably the original design I
would be willing to bet money on that
and you had to break in to Mars to get
it in the first place that must have
been it alright codex what did I get
automap no I got a codex of some kind
what did I get
what was the codex it didn't even say
bow BFG 1000 oh yes literally using
technology to drive from the BFG 9000
the design plan called for a massive
particle cannon to be built on the
orbiting moon the BFG 10,000 the largest
man-made weapon at platform ever
conceived wields enough firepower to
defend against even the most officiated
of capital great FTL cruisers in
existence or against the eventual
potentiality of a space bound demonic
threat which I don't see the sky seems
to be very empty of those this such
things wet war dead oh hi when did you
get behind me
oh I need us I need a cutscene for a
ladder like to see him try what hi
what's up
me and my classic armor yeah
a damn because this does seem very
introductory it's got all these other
humans that are like holy [ __ ] oh please
let me actually shoot this thing
please let me actually shoot it I need
you to tell me that I can actually
oh my god oh my god really
I just pull it out and there's the BFG
what a missed opportunity just let me do
it you gotta just let me do it I'm so
sad what's fascinating is this is a very
tight level it's very tightly designed
but at the same time it's just like God
why did you not let me aim and fire it
oh this is like I wanted I know it
looked like I did but because I didn't
have the clicky of it it didn't feel
like I did it is such a disconnect such
a missed opportunity there it is so
simple it's so simple let me shoot Mars
if you're gonna put me in charge of a
gun that's gonna shoot Mars let me shoot
Mars hi I'm having a moment go away all
right I'm over it I'm over it I'm over
it
Wow see I would have loved to know that
I did that that is gonna mess up Mars
for a long time well you know one way to
terraform Mars is just a new kit so uh
yeah that that happened all right cool
let's go to Mars then this is odd it
does feel whoa okay dead space damn damn
damn damn damn damn damn damn facilities
down to the Mars
ah huh damn damn damn that's cool damn
if only I had been the one to hold the
trigger I mean this is don't get me
right this is super cool I'm just like
oh come on guys please oh really
not me oh it's just one of the things
I'm doing but ah ah but that would have
been really Oh
ooh this does seem like first level
spectacle that they were probably going
I've wondered cuz cuz they delayed the
game right you know they delayed the
game probably for some redesigns and
probably to redo some things I need to
get that mastery whatever this is
precision Bowl master I don't know what
to do stop
who's controlling you how do we shut you
up there better be something in this
game that shuts that person up or that
computer program up because that that's
just a bit much okay where am I going
here what am i doing oh you still firing
there buddy boo who's firing you
what's firing you how are you still
firing who's in control
oh you guys are empowered where is the
totem I don't see it
it was also another way to go around
there let me go there first it seems
like there might be something over there
[Music]
locked of course it is okay I'm coming
to fight here I am bump okay cool where
is this totem oh my god you guys are not
just what the hell with your undulating
sonic rings of doom what the hell was
that my goodness these where's oh there
it is God how did I miss that the one
place I didn't go in this whole endeavor
alright now you guys met when their
totem dup they move a million miles an
hour
it is no joke alright now they got mad
at that a little alright good yeah down
I go hello what's down here something
fun I imagine what's over here pretty
pretty pretty pretty very pretty calm oh
that's a whole lot of nothing all right
I'm doing good see you thank you big
priest victory victory oh and then we
got this thing let me get my are bolused
ready
little overkill well they did it I'm the
best go I thought it was gonna be a
butthole all right is that everything
down there probably
doodle-ooh doodle-ooh i OC Oh with
suddenly I'm locked off in an elevator
again so strange
hello oh you thought I'd miss you no no
no that's cute that's cute those toys
are pretty cute
I gotta go back and get the rest of the
toys cuz it is kind of fun
how are you still getting ammo
everything is destroyed what are you
shooting at I really want to know what
what do you think you're shooting at
oh you're shooting de bris Oh
interesting
Oh interesting damn it's just going for
it alright cool good for you cannon
operation
[Music]
[Laughter]
be generous ok see I like a nose was
like that more than just the Slayers no
piece of [ __ ] you know just like really
really like seriously taking it
seriously the ridiculousness of it I
like those announcements those are good
cuz that's what it would be it'd be like
corporate motivational slogans but uh D
modified you know what I mean hmm I
think I got everything here yeah pretty
much or I'm coming for you baby with my
sweet teleporter I'm gonna teleport I'm
gonna tell oh my god oh my god really
oh my god yes I love this this this I've
seen this where have I seen this there
must have been a redesign of the game oh
my god how that shoot me in a space
that's Indiana Jones level of surviving
the nuke and a fridge there's no way
that's so ridiculous I love it God but
that's borderline too much that's really
close I don't know I love it I still
love it it's but that's close so that's
pretty close
oh but I loved it but man come on guys
your skirt in the line there but I love
it you're lucky I love it but hey watch
yourself but man that was awesome that
was really cool but really stupid if you
think about it but really yeah quite
dumb quite dumb very very dumb but cool
ah damn I miss
your gun but dumb but dumb dumb cool
thank you
where am I going I might even go on the
right way I have no idea anymore hi hi
oh how do I get up there hi hi that's a
waste of bullets damn it missed wouldn't
be a waste of bullets if I didn't miss
up up up up up up up thank you thank you
nice coins okay there's something up
yonder way
whoop
whoa doom 64 intro you say hope and hope
and a hope
BAM love it hi hello everybody my name
is markiplier well I'm here to destroy
you now please do not resist this is for
your own good uh how do I get to you now
well that's a puzzle am I missing
something
oh I'm in the wrong place am I in the
wrong place how do they end up going the
wrong foot the wrong way wait what what
happened whoa oh oh I just need to drop
down Oh God
that threw me for a loop that's a big
football hole oh you mean that didn't do
anything I thought I was gonna kill
somebody
okay all right boom portal where am I
going
I'm up here now where all right cool
or really what
done easy easy easy there are so many
more enemies in this level who the hell
do you think you are get out of my face
you sassy bastards oh I hate you you're
not so cute you're not very cute at all
you're actually the opposite of cute I
find you disgusting oh and then I would
end up here and then I'd be able to go
out here and then I would be able to go
down here now it's all adding up now it
all makes sense oh all right then
whoa cool nope hello
where am I going dudes and dudettes am I
going over there sure seems like it
whoa here I go I'm here now I'm gonna
time this perfectly
I am timing at the opposite of ah oh oh
the opposite of perfectly oh I'm an
[ __ ] come on you're really gonna
knock me back that far
just for me being an idiot really oh
come on guys also how is there gravity
how is there any sort of gravity also
wouldn't I wouldn't I kind of like
destroy the planet
have it have I haven't I destroyed the
planet
I believe I've destroyed the planet from
downtown oh no please please feel it
look like this oh god please
oh god no not like this I'm so I'm in it
to win it
yes yes yes I'm alive oh hey buddy hey
how you doing all right hang on God do a
few things little maintenance little
house cleanup you know how it is Bam Bam
blood punch baby's blood punch baby Oh
God let me no not like this not like
this not like this
. so that their the war big star fro
Oh waitin dude you're in for asked way
ting oh I'll take whatever you needed in
there and I'm pretty sure it was
important
yes finally finally I got to do whoa
well I got just self-destructed because
he was afraid to fight me and I I
understand that yes please thank you I
am full of BFG ammo you're telling me
that I should have used my BF G at that
point is that what you're explaining to
me that what you're saying to me that
sure seems like what you're saying to me
but to be perfectly honest I did not
need it I am just that amazing it is
true in every way shape or form I am
incredible oh now the door opens good
Greg Greg right exactly what I said
before
hi you're a grumpy Gus goodbye
any secrets oh good thing those don't
hurt me it's a damn good thing oh oh oh
there goes hi friends this is cool I got
me this is a cool level it's kind of
funky I like it I like it a lot okay
there is a one up at the tippy top of
this station here now how does one get
whoa all right
interesting choice well how does one get
to the tippy top of that station it is
beyond my limited capacity to understand
I must launch myself from here I'm
willing to bet oh my goodness fool god
damn and I'm not trying it again it's
just a 1-up who cares oh maybe this was
a mistake out of a shake who made it
made it made it hey bud cheers I blew up
a planet well not me I didn't actually
push the button but you know whose
economy I was in the vicinity I was I
was watching I was watching as it
happened which is just as cool right
most people would agree right who would
agree that that's just a school that's a
lot of kaboom I am more BFG mo it really
wants me to use the BFG but be vertical
honest I don't feel like I need it let's
say you can give me a compelling reason
to do so I'm not seeing it though I'm
really not seeing it I'll hoard it until
the end of my days it's like any game
that gives you a very limited resources
like ah yeah of course never spend it
there was a comic about that never spend
it got it totally fun
loud and clear we'll never in my life
ever use it understood I know what
you're talking about buddy
whoo-hoo God all right now's the time
I'm gonna use it
goodbye planet maybe that'll blow it up
maybe that's what the count is blowing
up the planet it's almost just as good
feels just as good definitely anyway I'm
gonna go get that ammo now knowing a
risk wasting and that'd be horrible
hello who's here
anybody more secrets oh yeah there's a
battery up here now how do I get up dill
maybe come at it from this angle no no
no no no no stop stop stop no no no no
no no no no no no no definitely no oh
here we go
hi mister guy your pipe bastard
[Music]
and here we go got it thank you
I earned that just like I earned blowing
up Mars very very earned that who
finally I was actually wondering when I
was gonna get on one of these that being
super heavy lasts longer yeah let's do
that
antelope crew did baby shove it in me
get it in me who needs a face full of
kaboom so where am I going after that
you say go over there and you say that
less if it's just like an easy thing to
do
oh it is an easy thing to do hi I don't
trust you
get out of my way I need to move
everyone's just volunteering to die
give me know this thank you goodbye
[Music]
fungus why everything is like dying
before me and the stupid butthole
tentacles were the ones that actually
give me agita that's okay it's all good
now how do I get up there maybe it's not
a matter of getting up there as opposed
to getting around huh
that's pretty locked up tight okay but
if I go down is that really gonna let me
get where I need to go maybe maybe I
just look I just gotta make sure that I
don't leave the area before I actually
get where I need to go maybe or not or
maybe I'm gonna find it right here hi
all right see you around say it
dough pinky oh that's cute alright see
ya bud you're that open that that didn't
open those I did open this so how do I
open those is the question oh and this
will not let me climb on that so it's
definitely not that so how do I get to
it okay there's a there's something
there how do I get there I'll come back
for this one
ah okay well I don't need anyone to
believe because it doesn't really matter
if they do or not I'm still gonna kick
ass what are these oh these are escape
pods okay so if I don't do this I bet
that would like get me huge guts great
for ripping and tearing it alright so
there's got to be a way I have to figure
this out because if I don't do this I'm
not gonna get this Slayer gate and then
I'm not gonna yeah alright but they're
cool then I'm not gonna get the unmake
er so I have to get this oh this oh it's
a freaking button that was right there
that I could have pressed at any time
but I didn't because I'm dumb ah that
makes things so much easier yeah of
course and then there she is just right
there and then you know what the souther
secret I could have gotten it's a push
of a button here I was trying to Wow
yeah now that didn't vote for me but now
I can do the thing yay I'm ready I'm
gonna use my big gun mm-hmm oh my Oh a
marauder now that's an interesting
challenge alright okay okay alright so I
want to mop up everything else before I
start working on him oh he's persistent
oh he really what are you woah what was
that what was that thing you're there
but what was that other thing what is oh
hey hi alright your maker drones oh hi
whoa hey whoa oh oh oh easy zzzzz easy
buddy okay got oh I'm stuck I'm getting
stuck on stuff I don't want to do that
it's not my thing
Oh what you killed me but the other one
went down like nobody's business
come on
all right ah stop it oh my god oh there
we go
headbutt you out of existence how were
you out no no no the stupid dog
stupid dog you make me look bad this guy
is just a straight-up shotgun battle I
know it the only thing that I feel right
of fighting him as just the shotgun are
you that come on tell me give me come on
USAC so it's like every time I stagger
him that these guys spun like a bunch of
dick holes what you doing what you doing
what you miss me you wanna kiss me that
took all of my gas but I needed it for
the bullets oh yeah buddy yeah come on
come on
ah miss me good you are not gonna kiss
me I don't care how much you want it
well hi thanks for getting in the middle
of my fight oh oh you suck oh god he
killed himself
oh you scrub oh you got to uh fights not
over oh you killed yourself oh you got
stuck in the ceiling you [ __ ] I win I
won t time baby oh alright hey wait I
got a I actually got a concentrate
because I don't lose at this point after
that amazing amazing finish oh oh you
also I'm stuck oh my god this is the
greatest day of my life
this is the greatest day mothers
officially the greatest day in my life
give me through that portal baby whoa
Nellie
oh I love it I love it I love it this is
my favorite favorite thing favorite
thing ever
favorite thing
I'm coming for you from downtown oh yeah
oh oh no your throat I love the super
shotgun I could use it all day and never
grow tired of it
it is the best weapon in the game by far
a million ways from Sunday it is the
best thank you
you got froze oh no what a match what an
amateur I was about to say what amateur
what I never noticed wha bye-bye bye-bye
hmm that that was fun
not gonna lie that might have been the
most fun one yet the frickin Marauder
got stuck and died like a scrub like a
scrub like the scrubby scrub in the
history of scrub 'dom he got stuck in
rage quitted that's what I think
happened there he just couldn't help
himself and he rage quitted I think
that's a great point to end this episode
on thank you so much everybody for
watching I am so enjoying this game it
is so much fun I can't tell you how much
fun I'm having and now that I'm like
mastering the super shotgun for the
mobility of it I am just oh I'm just
having a goddamn delight playing this
game so thank you everybody so much for
watching more episodes to come I don't
know how far we into this game but
probably a lot of game left to go so
look forward to that coming at you very
soon thanks again and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]